each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
thanks very much I'm thrilled to be here
and I'm going to talk about facilitating
next generation data-intensive science
using semantic technologies and this is
joint work with my colleague at rpi
Peter Fox who have worked with for a
number of years when I was at Stanford
and he was a 10-car so I'm going to talk
a little bit about building the
foundations for semantic e science which
is a trend that Peter and I have been
working on along with our teams for
almost a decade now I came in from the
from the artificial intelligence side
and so my goal is to use our official
intelligence and service of the next
generation of science which I believe
and many people believe is
interdisciplinary distributed
collaborative East science and from a
scientist a natural scientist goal or
actually any scientist goal we want to
enable scientists to interact access
interact and collaborate on what looks
like a global distributed knowledge base
of data that looks like it's integrated
it looks like it's locally available but
there's a lot of challenges when we're
working in the natural science world
we're typically getting our data for
many different instruments using a lot
of different protocols using tons of
vocabularies if you're in the room that
I was in bright before this we're
arguing about vocabularies using
sometimes unstated assumptions often
inconsistent or evolving metadata and
everything is evolving your data is
evolving your metadata is evolving so
what I'm going to do in this talk is I'm
going to give a few highlights from
semantically enabled science efforts
that Peter and I have done over the last
about seven years highlight a couple of
things from my team's knowledge
provenance efforts and use both of those
to motivate a new project that we just
got called the semantic e science
framework which if you're following the
press RP I wrote a little press
announcement about this and it just took
off I think because when we were one of
the larger efforts that was funded under
the American Recovery and
re shoot what is that but a ra effort
and I provided one link for that which
is basically our next-generation effort
to make it go beyond any particular
science area to do it across many
science areas so an early project that
we did was a virtual solar terrestrial
Observatory from a computer scientist
viewpoint like mine I'm interested in
this because it's an interdisciplinary
virtual observatory and I was working
with somebody who did solar and
Atmospheric Research and so from his
perspective it was great that he and his
colleagues could access the data
seamlessly and from my perspective I
helped enable the next generation of
science and our goal was to be a
distributed scalable education and
research environment to let scientists
do what they typically do search for
data integrated and analyze it and we
were aiming at PhD researchers which
while ultimately we want to aim at the
world initially it's easier to aim at
the PhD researchers because you don't
have to do quite as much on your
interfaces this project covers solar
solar terrestrial and space physics but
as you'll see the infrastructure has
been used in a lot of different science
areas and it provided virtual access it
still provides it went into service
actually after less than a year of
funding which I was really happy about
and so it's been up now I think for
about four years and it was aimed at one
entry disciplinary area solar and
solar-terrestrial physics but we've used
it in areas including volcanology
atmospheric climate response plate
tectonics now oceans and it's at the
basis of a couple of follow-on projects
one of which is the semantic provenance
capture and data in just systems this is
an NSF funded project that's trying to
capture more provenance in at the
beginning so considering smart
instruments so the data comes smart
annotated off the instrument so that you
don't have to go back and add Providence
after the fact it starts with a
background ontology sorry if
beyond what your eyes allow you to read
but it's got an instrument hierarchy
information about observatories
information about data products and
information about services that get the
data and it turned out that while this
was done by a fairly small group a
couple of scientists natural scientists
initially did it and then we vetted it
with larger and larger groups and
although it was aimed in these very
specific areas it it turns out that it
was very simple to expand it to cover
radically different science areas and
now what we're doing in now we're kind
of in the third generation of this we're
modularizing it and taking out the
things that our atmosphere specific or
solar terrestrial physics specific and
making them in separate modules and then
we're using the infrastructure across
general science areas it uses the
background ontology to help filter the
information what was one thing that was
really powerful about the system is
before scientists had to come in and do
it in a very standard methodology I
always had to start with their dates and
then go to the instrument and they had
to know the instrument code and they had
to know the dates they couldn't say oh
well during a period of high geomagnetic
activity which is one thing they wanted
to do there to know that that was from
March second of two thousand foot
forward to something else and now you
can come in in any direction as enabled
by the ontology and you don't have to
know where the data resides the system
actually can go out and wrap the calls
and pull the data in and integrate it in
a way that previously scientists had to
do and also previously you had to know
what parameters to pull together so when
i tried to use these interfaces not
being trained in solar terrestrial
physics i had a very hard time doing it
because i just didn't have enough
subject matter expertise to actually
make meaningful queries but now i can
use it other people can use it who don't
have the same level of training and you
can filter by particular domains
particular instruments you can see the
instrument hierarchy expose scientists
really seem to like this and what it
allows them to do is
find instruments that make sense for the
kind of data that they're looking to
capture when they didn't know those
instruments existed so you finding data
that's appropriate for your use case
without having to know exactly where it
was there's a lot of different ways that
you can see it you hear you can look at
instruments on North America you can
choose particular kinds of instruments
I'm not live here but if I were to click
things I could see the particular kind
of interferometers and then I could
capture data based on that so we're
leveraging lightweight semantic
technologies both lightweight ontology
is in the background and lightweight
kind of web two point O things tools to
enable the next generation of scientific
virtual Observatory in another follow on
to this we didn't make available the
Providence when we were providing access
to the pictures so here montolo solar
observatory is one place that we're
deployed and one of the pieces of data
that you might get back are these images
of the Sun and these images are actually
generated from a whole lot of data sets
that are created over many different
time periods by a lot of different
observers and sorry again if you had
better eyesight than I do you could
actually see the annotations on this
picture about that weather conditions
when this was collected who collected it
any doubt that they had about the data
and so now the image is actually comes
with the provenance and before what you
actually had to do was you had to go to
a handwritten log if you could get it or
call somebody if you could find the
right person to call to actually find
out what was going on when that data was
collected so this is actually the the
workflow that actually generates the
data that comes from mls oh and it comes
from Hawaii it goes to places in
Colorado there's a lot of different data
managers who actually touch it and in
the old days you were incredibly lucky
if at the end you could get back to the
result of one person touching it which
means that you don't get the data that
comes from this person or that person or
that person touching it
nor do you get the data that comes from
all these processes that actually
updated the data so you're kind of at
the mercy of having this data deliver to
you you don't know what actually went on
and so if you're going to try to reuse
it you don't really have enough
information to figure out whether it's
accurate for your uses without making
phone calls or looking up in some kind
of paper log but now what we have is
using some background semantic
technologies so we use an expanded
version and a slightly modularized
version of the vsto ontology and we use
the provenance ontology from the proof
markup language and in another room we
were just chatting about the providence
markups and we use a data quality
ontology to inform the queries and my
display up here just disappeared and
these instruments instead of just piping
out data they actually pipe out data
along with the annotations some of which
are automatically generated so you know
actually a timestamp on when the the
instrument generated that data but now
also we capture the seeing logs and the
observer logs along with it
its back thank you you guys wouldn't see
that another project that's very new the
scientific observations network it's
just been funded that kickoff meeting
was just a couple weeks ago in Santa
Barbara it's a community driven effort
to have scientific observations network
to do a semantic interoperability of
environmental and ecological data so the
goal is similar to these other areas we
want to have a community sanctioned
evolving data model in this case for
observational data for ecological and
environmental data we want to build the
network at practitioners and we want to
collect a repository of motivating use
cases all to enable interoperability
across the resources for environmental
and ecological data and its leverage out
so there's a website up here that you
can go look at for the use case
collection and for the starting points
these are the observation models that
we're starting from and we're doing an
analysis across them to see which ones
make the most sense to reuse and then
from these will actually generate the
scientific observations data model that
we will use the same kind of methodology
if the science community to vet more and
more and use that to actually share our
data in another project this one's for
you in the back in another project
that's nasa-funded we're trying to help
people predict the climate response to a
volcanic eruption so essentially what we
want to do is capture enough information
of this picture that's provided from
NASA about what happens when a volcano
erupts about what goes up into what
levels of the atmosphere what processes
happen what comes down into the portions
of the atmosphere that we care about
what might go up further where what
happens to the ash and then we might
want it ultimately so that the first
problem that we're trying to address
here is how do we predict climate
response but other problems we want to
predict or help people predict is if
you're close to this volcano
when should you evacuate and what kind
of person should you evacuate just a
person with asthma or any person and so
what we want to be able to do is help
them answer the questions that they care
about so this question is one of my
favorites because when I first heard it
I said huh my role often in knowledge
acquisition is to ask the stupid
questions and say you know what what
actually is this so scientists want to
answer questions like determine the
statistical signatures above volcanic
and solar for scenes on the height of
the tropopause and so if I'm going to
instruct a machine on how to answer
those questions I have to understand
what this stuff is enough to get it into
the machine so that they understand what
it is and better I actually want to
understand why they care so I asked the
guy who generated this this question
said you know why one what does that
mean and why you're asking it and he
says well I'm looking for bad things I'm
looking for bad things like acid rain
and the part of the atmosphere that we
experience and actually more than that
i'm looking to predict when acid rain is
going to happen so i'm going to look for
indicators of acid rain and some
indicators of acid rain are statistical
signatures and it's really important in
certain areas of the atmosphere in
particular at the height of the
tropopause so that's a little bit of
background but what he actually does as
he gives us a whole lot of background it
says you know in order to solve this
problem I look at all this stuff I look
at tropical mountains i look at acidic
mab magma and you know it goes on but
ultimately we need to figure out what
pieces of this we have to capture so
that the machine can actually help to
figure out when acid rain is going to
happen and when the indicators are
present or getting worse or getting
better so we need to capture that
information in some way we do it in
ontology 'he's we look at starting
points for the anthologies the Semantic
Web earth and environmental terminology
is a pretty well used a background
ontology that's kind of a mid-level
science ontology and so what you see
here is portions of sweet that have been
augmented with basically the terms that
you saw some of the terms on the
previous page that help us answer those
kinds of questions
and one of the things that I really like
about this effort is sweet when we first
started using it was a monolithic
ontology which if you've been in some of
the other sessions you've heard some
people say those things can be pretty
hard to use so my background some people
call me mrs. ontology I've built
ontology is for a lot of years and the
environments for the ontology and I who
pretty well trained in this kind of
stuff I find it difficult to use these
giant monolithic ontologies when
particularly in this case in which is
common this covered much more breath
than I needed and it didn't cover nearly
enough depth that I needed and so I had
to figure end I'm not an expert in this
particular domain so I need to pull some
starting place from from somewhere
preferably from something that's got
credentials that a lot of the science
community likes but I don't want all
that other stuff that's cluttering my
brain saying you know what's the
definition of this only to come back
three hours later to figure out I didn't
really need to know that so as a result
of this effort we actually worked with
the authors of sweet and we ended up
helping them modular eyes it and now
it's much more modular ontology and it's
seeing much greater reuse so a couple of
highlights from this theme of these four
selected projects the background
semantic technologies we use reasoning
they allowed us to do unified query
workflow so now you can come in in any
order of the workflow also there's a
radically decrease input requirement in
many of our evaluations so we've done
evaluations I think now four years at
the primary science meetings and they
all come back and say one I don't have
to type as much to you kept me from
making the the dumb answers basically
once you answer one thing that precludes
something else now the interface doesn't
let you make that stupid answer which
well that uninformed answer a better way
of saying it so the interface is only
let you do syntactically correct queries
and more importantly they also or
equally importantly they let you do
semantically correct queries we have
better query support so that you don't
have to put as much in the query because
the machine can actually figure out
things for you and we also let you do
semantic integration so you don't have
to identify that i want that data set in
that data set I just want the data
that's appropriate for my query so what
we did was we used a number of al based
tools we've seen a lot of slides on
protégé and pellet a reasoner for Al and
we used some service wrappers to get
into the data stores the primary ones
for vsto are listed here but we have
wrapped other data stores we used our
inference web infrastructure for
explanation because one of the things
that we found over and over again that
it's if I give you if my smart system
gives you an answer you say why should I
believe you and by the way where did
that come from and maybe how recent is
it and is it authoritative so we're
using our inference web infrastructure
to provide information about where the
data came from and we've found in a
number of projects that this basic
infrastructure has been extensible in a
lot of different areas so the themes
from that come back to me as a computer
science researcher are all of these
efforts and other that came out from
other efforts as well not just the ones
that I'm talking about we have an
increased need for prominence we have
radically increased need for community
building vetting and evolving of the
background knowledge the anthologies
there's also a growing need for linking
the data together and there is more and
more need for reuse and things that
facilitate reuse like modular ization so
these things actually come back and
drive the research that we do on the
computer science side and on the
Semantic Web site so one of the things
that I've been leading an effort on an
inference web for a number of years to
just to make systems actionable so if I
give you an answer what does it take for
you to take action in a reasonable
period of time no sir not two years to
know enough to say
a ok that meets my needs I'm going to
click or I'm going to buy or I'm going
to integrate and so our answer to that
is knowledge provenance interoperable
knowledge provenance and infrastructure
to support that so our goals are to
provide interoperability provenance
information explanations in ways that
you can consume it and trust information
for both the encoding and four ways of
predicting trust and essentially this
provenance it can be viewed as another
kind of linked data on the web so are in
terlingua for that is the proof markup
language which started as a way of
encoding reasoner's results of theorem
provers but it's evolved to be a way of
encoding information for anything that
manipulates data and while I like pml
and one of the co-authors of it I don't
say that that's the only one because
it's clear that there's a number of
provenance in terlingua is out there
proposed into linguas and i'm a member
of the newly formed provenance incubator
group coming out w 3c i think we'll all
probably migrate to some well I'll
ignore that oh it's back to some
something that w3c suggests but it's
probably going to have very much of the
fundamentals of how do i encode who what
when and where how do i encode how you
manipulated what you did to it what kind
of statistical manipulations or sounded
complete logical manipulations and if I
trust you and you trust eveline maybe I
want to trust deviling to even if I've
never met her before because I trust you
so much so I might want to encode that I
might want to have algebra for
propagating that trust information it's
motivated from a lot of different places
and because of time I think I'm only
going to mention this one where we're
connected with the thousands of problems
for theorem provers where we've got
literally thousands of proofs for the
same question from a lot of different
places and then somebody might want to
say can I get to this answer different
ways do some things depend on different
sources are some of them unreliable and
can some of the bin
maybe one's the fast way to get the
answer but it's a horrible way to
explain it to somebody and maybe in
other ones the better way to explain it
but it's kind of slow so it comes from a
lot of different settings that we've
deployed it in and we encode it in a
background ontology and it's encoded in
al but this isn't really meant for human
consumption this is just meant from a
machine consumption so that you can push
the provenance around along with the
data so those are the foundations on
which we're building the semantic
e-science framework and it's driven by a
broad range of use cases not just for
the PhD researcher but also aimed for
the educator so that actually means that
your vocabulary needs to expand and your
presentation style needs to expand and
potentially some of your methods need to
expand its configuration and profile
driven e-science framework so we need to
have domain and design pattern ontology
support we're working on a modular
ization of the domain neutral stuff as
well as the domain specific stuff and
actually we think that it's a
significant contribution to have the
domain specific stuff in modules as well
because I can't tell you how many phone
calls from getting from natural
scientists X who says hi I really need
an ontology in one of the more
interesting ones for me was immune
epitopes which I actually had never
really heard I couldn't have given you a
definition when that researcher called
me but I'm now published in a journal of
immunology on my ontology of immune
epitopes along with those people of the
experts and we need some set of those
ontology surround for people to reuse so
that every person who needs to know
something about immunology doesn't have
to build their own so we're working on
this domain neutral and domain specific
set of ontology that's open source and
community driven we think that it's
really important to push the next
generation of knowledge provenance as
well so actually this one is basically
vsto generalized our interdisciplinary
virtual Observatory generalized this one
is based
sickly our knowledge Providence
infrastructure specialized because that
was that had no knowledge of the setting
that it was in and we think that it's
much more powerful when you have some
knowledge the we really want
collaborators the initial collaborators
that we're spending more time with our
the marine metadata interoperability
efforts sweet Hui sonnet the scientific
observations Network the Woods Hole
Institute and the oceans observing
initiative and we're actually also using
it as the basis of our semantic e
science class we're doing a couple of
test bed implementations because one of
the things that we found was when we
have in an implemented system that we
make available that has like a simple
little use case people can pick it up
copy it and then do some implementation
in their own domain and it's a three or
NSF project that just started literally
two weeks ago and to advertisements come
to consider coming to the international
prominence in an annotation workshop if
you care about the Providence piece and
AI needs linked data I think is one
thing that's going to be another game
changer so when we use the artificial
intelligence along with a massive amount
of data that's out there to do a better
job of linking it and accessing it I
think we're going to see something
equivalent well I don't know about
equivalent something interesting like
the Wikipedia and the semantic wikis so
with that oh okay so with that the the
directions that we're taking is for the
increased need for Providence we're
doing the next generation of inference
web for growing need for community
building we're doing a lot of work on
making semantic wikis more accessible
and have more tools to make them more
usable and with the growing need for
linked data we're doing a big play on
the data.gov data and with the growing
need for reuse we're doing ontology
modularization and a lot of tools so
with that I'll open it for questions
I didn't mention that but really good
question so we so actually I had one I
didn't start it but I ended up owning
one of the larger ontology repositories
from about 15 years ago when i went to
Stanford at the knowledge systems lab
and actually we were going to do a
next-generation ontology repository
effort but mm I actually is doing a
serious play there so at the moment
we're supporting them and if it turns
out that it's better to do we've got
Providence web org because actually I
was just in a meeting last week with
people saying marine metadata you know
that doesn't really capture my notion of
environmental X or solar atmospheric why
so I have a feeling that we'll probably
end up moving someplace maybe the
problem its web org to allow an ontology
repository because I agree with you I
think I think the time has actually
passed to actually do the next
generation of that using today's
technology rather than yeah right and
actually I guess there aren't too many
PhD students in the room but I think
there's room for a couple of theses in
there I mean I know active work there
but I don't think any existing tool is
anywhere close to ready in fact when I
do a deployed project that's got a
critical path I use standard version
control stuff because I don't think
we're ready to do that stuff but
actually that would be a really good
thing for Microsoft the fun
the biggest challenge or maybe most
important hardest what's well so I think
Providence actually it's a product so I
didn't come to my research life saying I
was going to live and breathe provenance
I actually came saying i wanted to do
explanation and make stuff more usable
and what I got pushed back on was saying
if you don't give me who did it when you
know just go away I don't care how much
other work you do so I think Providence
is like the first step to almost
everything and actually the community
enablement so we've heard that been
really pushed that in the early talk and
I agree with that as well so I think
we're past the little science I mean
little science is important but science
that you can do alone incredibly
important but i think that the way we're
going to really make a big change is for
everybody in this room working together
so if we can't do the things that enable
the next generation of collaboration
we're missing the boat and I think we've
got the tools today that are good enough
starting points so like I think it
doesn't take my kids or my grandkids to
do it I think I can do it